just because it's in the interest of the
central banks and the government
the interests and the models of
keynesian economics and the government
are aligned doesn't mean they're wrong
so let's let's give them a chance
so the conventional wisdom
perhaps economics wisdom is that
inflation is good
uh in moderation as it encourages
spending but too much is bad because you
know it completely devalues destroys
people's savings so a little bit of
inflation is good to stimulate spending
um
and
i mean i suppose this is one of the
things that's supported by uh kenzie in
economics
basically the whole point of keynesian
economics is to try and find uh an
endless array of explanations to explain
why inflation is a good thing well it
could the chicken and the egg so that's
that's the cynical take yeah this is a
propaganda machine to solve the
government's narrative
the less cynical take is this a bunch of
economists who are telling who um
who figured out this thing and it
happens to be good for banks and
governments and just because it's good
for them doesn't mean and it justifies
the existence of government and uh your
basic
i don't think it's your basic assumption
but a foundational principle of your
thought is that a lot of government is
not a good thing
your first gut instinct
government bad
like i mentioned i live next door to
michael malus who probably beats you on
the intensity
and how quickly he says government bad
so
so but there you know there's a
potential argument for government good
go some government is good maybe a lot
of government is good maybe we need a
lot of centralized management
for resource allocation and so on
because we humans specialize we're too
busy and so on so there's an argument
for that uh that exists uh you probably
disagree with any possible argument in
that side but anyway so why is that idea
yeah of kensington economics wrong i'm
gonna focus for this on the
money idea the idea that a little bit of
inflation is good
um the idea here i mean the criticism
is that without inflation people
wouldn't spend and then the economy
would come to a grinding halt
and that's nonsensical because people
spend not because they want to keep this
magical monster called the economy going
people spend because they need to
consume because you know that's how we
live that's how we survive you need to
eat you need shelter you need clothes to
keep you warm
and as technology advances the
capabilities of the things that we can
do with our
um
with our time increases and so we want
to buy more things so people buy things
because people want to consume there's a
limitless desire to consume you know
that there's no
the
there's no um shortage of reasons for
people to consume whether it's food or
ferraris or
private jets people just always want to
buy more can i interrupt just really
quick what about the fear about the
uncertainty of the future where they
might want to they might want to
uh
buy things but they're really afraid
because it seems like there's a lot like
a pandemic going on or whatever it is
that's good so so fear of uncertainty is
yeah but can you have too much fear
here's the thing what i was saying is i
was making the point that
we don't need to be motivated to consume
like we have the insatiable desire to
consume everybody would like to have
more of all kinds of things everybody
would like to have a bigger house well
not everybody some people have a big
enough house but everybody would like a
house everybody would like a car jet
all kinds of things you know electronics
machines
so we don't need a desire to consume but
of course the limit on how much we
consume is
opportunity cost
why don't you buy a ferrari well because
that's really expensive and it would
mean that you know well maybe you do
have a ferrari but i mean most people
don't buy a ferrari because
it's too expensive they don't they can't
afford it they'd have to work too hard
to get it
um and if they do get it it might mean
that you know they can't afford their
house anymore so we have to economize
that's a good thing and we have to also
think of the future
and so humans consume that we don't need
more motivation to consume we have to
deal with the economic reality of the
things that limit us from consuming more
so
what keynesians present is that when
there is a problem in the economy like
there was after world war one
the problem is always a result caused by
the inflation
and what the keynesian hucksters do is
that they look at the inflation
at the consequences of inflation and
blame it on people not spending enough
when people are doing the rational thing
you know the money is
um the so there was inflation caused the
an unsustainable boom it caused the
recession and now a lot of people lost
their jobs and they don't have enough
money to go out and spend um frivolously
so they save for the future the future
is uncertain that's a good thing you
know that's how you fix things um you
begin the recovery by
well you know you lost some wealth so
you spend less like if you you know if
your business goes bust if you lose your
job
it's natural and smart that you stop
spending money on the frivolous things
that you used to spend
and you save it for the future you
invest in something else you get a new
job and then once you've recovered you
start spending more this is this is very
sane and very good and it's the way to
recovery
but
essentially the keynesians have used
this as a justification for more
inflation
because inflation is an addiction once
the government gets down the path of
spending money to solve its problems
then
every problem looks like it can be
solved by more inflation and so
this is where keynesian economics comes
in and of course the keynesian economics
is based on the work of keynes which
came in the 1930s
and this is the key point like um it's
portrayed in the textbook as if it's
just
this this scientific breakthrough that
you know somebody in the 1930s this
genius came about and realized that oh
we don't actually need gold we don't
need hard money we can actually just
print all the money
and in reality of course it was just the
very thin flimsy idiotic justification
for what governments were already doing
for 20 years they'd already gone off the
gold standard
and they'd gone through 20 years in
which they were lying to their
population telling their population
we're still on a gold standard but you
know
there are problems caused by various
random things but don't worry we're
going to be going back on the gold
standard 20 years later after they went
off the gold standard they come up with
this
justification for why oh actually the
gold standard was bad and and this is a
really pernicious thing about it is the
problems that were caused by us going
off the gold standard
were
caused by the gold standard and we're
going to fix them by going off the gold
standard even more just because
government is lying and it's shady and
it does these kinds of things doesn't
mean kenzian economics is wrong so just
because i wanted to separate a few
things you said uh it could very well be
very wrong uh and they could indeed be
hucksters all of these colorful such
colorful language uh i love you deeply
for this this is fun
you